next guest is well he was considered an
undersized system quarterback coming out
of Washington State which were both true
his closest comp was not an NFL
quarterback it was uncle Rico from
Napoleon Dynamite but he and his
mustache won the backup job in
Jacksonville and then went on to start
week one when Nick Foles got hurt he
went on to have an outstanding rookie
year now apparently touring the country
in an RV not bad please welcome the Jags
Gardner Minshew
I don't know how to describe the look
here a gardener but you look great you
look you lady Loggins esque maybe
someone done I'm alright
yeah Kenny what do you think Todd does
he look good see Evan I could totally
see any Loggins
I like that maybe a fifth get brother
okay it looks like your slang here you
got your shorts on you got your Snickers
what is that your chain you know I got
the sickest chain with me I was uh
so one Snickers hungers Player of the
Year pretty fired up about that this is
real by the way is that yeah it's real
real it's $75,000 and it's gonna be
auctioned off for Movember calls for
men's health awareness and Mental Health
Awareness so very excited about that
glad to be here partner with them now
did you drive your RV down here to Miami
no I had to turn in the RV yesterday
unfortunately that was and that was that
was a tough moment for me
grown very fond of the RV but uh where'd
you go so to go out from Mississippi
went west duck huntin East Texas Austin
Texas worked out of Permian high school
where they did Friday Night Lights I
want to tell you Rock Colorado for a
couple days which is like one of the
coolest place I've ever been to Las
Vegas where I got to fly with the Air
Force Thunderbirds like incredible
experience to Joshua Tree California
it's a Newport Beach for a few days and
then made my way on back did you do a TV
show
no I posted like four times on Instagram
and that was like plenty for me how's
this incredible tour I mean you should
have gotten a hold of Airstream and had
them sponsor it give you one of these
things and tour the yes I got sponsor
about travel camp in Jackson
they let me have three for a month and
for a couple difficult postman is it's
all good man what do you get on the
street when somebody sees you here at
the Super Bowl what's the one question
you get what's one question I get it's
usually something about fantasy football
and that's that's like everybody asks
about fantasy football
some people ask about Mike Leach which I
enjoy talking about and then it's either
the RV or the mustache yeah but I don't
get why somebody would ask you about
fantasy football
yeah oh no it's a big deal now man I
know that but I would think there's so
many other things that yeah you could
ask you about you would think are you
planning on being the starter next year
I hope to be the starter I plan on
working to be the starter and you know
trying to prove that every day on there
how would you describe your circuitous
route to get to the NFL yeah I think
doing that prepared me as well as
anything you know go into four different
schools learning four different offenses
being in four new locker rooms where you
have to you know make relationships and
earn guys trust and respect I think all
that really prepared me for this year
all right but you had you could have
gone to Alabama now give me the quote if
it's right that my cleats the legendary
offense it might a coach who left
Washington state but he was there we
just had him on did he say we're gonna
lead the nation in passing you want to
be you want to lead the nation in
passing then you come here if not you
stay at Alabama yeah he said do you want
to go sit on the bench at Alabama or
come here and leave the country and pass
that's pretty good recruiting yeah it's
not bad it's gonna sound south and then
you led the nation in passing that's
right yeah what was it about though
leach because he usually if you're a
quarterback with Mike Leach you're gonna
lead the nation in passing what is it
about his offensive genius though no II
just simplifies things so well you know
it's it's all about what the defense is
giving you that's what everybody thinks
it's about just throw every play but
it's really about taking what they give
you and Counting numbers and just really
chasing space on the field wait wait
slow that down now say it in my terms no
counting numbers and chasing space yes
oh it's common sense football like all
right we have three guys over here they
have two all right let's throw it out
there okay they we have three they have
four all right let's go to the other
shot you know so it just gets common
sense football at its
you know how to spruce how are you with
the line of scrimmage though in having
freedom at Washington State with Mike
Leach oh you have a complete freedom you
know a lot of times what you're getting
is you're getting a formation and check
and that means you call the play and
that's you know that's something that's
earned and now there's I was very
fortunate to you know even just in a
year to get that you know responsibility
you didn't get to do that with the Jags
though did you not but when you go to
line scrimmage so you have one plane
then there's a check to another plays
that what you're saying Washington State
yeah no so you have your whole playbook
at the line of scrimmage and that's
what's so unique the play books not very
big but you have access to all of it so
he trusts you to put us in the right
looks and that's what I think you know
is the biggest thing that prepares you
as you move to the next level Texas Tech
I think had a plate called six and it
was for Crabtree and and I think people
see Texas yeah and then they said why do
you call it six because it's going for
six point it's four verticals you know
they that's who they started with how
mommy and things lavell Edwards that'd
be what you
they started the four of articles and
yeah and stop how was that Coach Saban
when you talk to him
Saban like he's a guy when he walks in
the room like you feel you feel his
presence I you know he's there Lee is uh
you know it's different being with him
he's a very serious guy but you know
somebody you obviously respect as soon
as he walks in those business yeah
didn't sound like much fun he's business
yeah he would have made you cut your
hair with woody probably so he wouldn't
have appreciated it as much when you did
meet uncle Rico for Napoleon Dynamite
there's the first time I saw you that's
when I saw the must I said it looks like
uncle Rico for Napoleon Dynamite did you
even know who on cool Rico was from
Napoleon Dynamite oh absolutely have
watch said no too many times yeah so
that was his right as you got you
finished fifth in the Heisman yep did
you get to go to New York no day that
was ridiculous I've never been in New
York I had wait I like it'd have been
way more fun if they did just let me go
yeah so that's pretty disappointing
because she had Kyler and then too
the lane hounds doing Haskins yeah will
Grier yeah so I think they were worried
about you in New York yeah still the
show you know and finished fifth
I guess so they made the right call what
is Brandon Mississippi like Brandon
Mississippi is awesome it's a community
first off you know it's it's you know
and everything is kind of around the
high school like high school football
there is as good as you're gonna see you
know pack stadium there's tailgating you
know it's it's a big deal
do they have a street sign for Gardner
Minshew
oh I think they got a sign up at the
high school but they don't have a street
named after you I don't think so unless
they've done it in the last week or so
yeah well what do you have to do to get
a street named after you in Brandon
Mississippi yeah oh no there's not a
bunch of new roads or anything
who was the quarterback or player that
you met that kind of I'm not gonna say
took your breath away but you were like
whoa I'm talking to who
yeah meetin breezes Drew Brees after the
game playing the Saints now that was
really cool he's always got looked up to
you know because you know being kind of
an undersized guy was like alright if he
can do it you know that maybe maybe I
can do it so that was really cool get
chance for Jersey no he wasn't he wasn't
playing unfortunately so did you ask for
any jerseys this year ooh yeah Demario
Davis from the Saints he played in my
high school he's for Brandon Oh so we
got to do a swap and that was that was
really really cool when you look at
Patrick mahomes he makes it look easy
now somebody who plays the position it's
not that easy
what separates mahomes here yeah I think
the stuff off schedule you know when he
gets outside of the pocket you know he's
super creative and he has the arm to put
it literally wherever he wants on the
field and that's you know deep inside to
cover for so long against those guys and
it gets really really hard okay but if
you're building the perfect quarterback
if I start with arm whose arm do you
want for the perfect quarterback yeah
they're you taking Pat okay for sure if
I want legs legs mmm I mean I think you
go cam
ham over Lamar oh yeah you probably say
Lamar my ability at the line of
scrimmage to process in real-time I take
Peyton Manning really yeah
where does Brady go and into any of this
yeah he's definitely up there but like
he's not a guy that's gonna blow you
away with any one physical trait but
he's just so consistent his mental
approach to the game is this good you
know what is it about Peyton though when
you you know because we look at
quarterbacks who've changed the game and
Peyton is one of those few quarterbacks
who changed the game when you go to the
line of scrimmage and he sees what
you're doing and he knows what you're
going to do and there's nothing you
could do about it yeah that's got to be
pretty powerful yeah that's just you
know obsessive like pursued for
greatness that he's owned you know the
amount of time the work that he puts in
he's gonna know everything that you're
doing before you do it could you do that
if they give you total autonomy in
Jacksonville I'm working towards that
that's that's something I want to be
able to do but you know that's something
you know he didn't do it as rookie year
you know it's a time thing and you know
you build those hours you put the time
in and eventually hopefully get to the
point of understanding where you can do
that stuff how can you be friends with
somebody that you're competing with yeah
Nick Foles a good guy how can he wants
that job and you want that job ya know
because I think you care more about the
person than you do about the player you
know I love Nick as a brother as you
know as a person before anything else
football wise so I think you know
anytime Island he's out there I'm his
number one fan and vice versa you know
so we're both going for the same thing
we both want to see each other do well
and I think when we do that it's gonna
make us better
Paulie bring out Nick Foles here let's
say hello to Nick full
all right I have your I got your draft
profile here yeah you want to read it
sir okay breeze read it
JJ actually breathes in JJ Watt asked to
keep a copy they wanted to keep that
breeze was so upset really he was he's
like can I keep this because I'm putting
this in my locker
yeah all right so I'll start below
average height for an NFL quarterback
that's a fact okay now that we can do
there okay I'm still growing though so
at the combine I was six foot in 7/8 and
pro day I was six one so I think I'm
still getting up there so we'll see
where I end up you got taller
yes I'm still growing Wow Congrats
so benefited from a scheme that allowed
an abundance of one-on-ones yeah I mean
I guess you'd rather play in a bad
scheme like yeah man this guy he really
played for a crappy coach that's good
you know awful game against Washington
after dominating lesser defenses in
conference
yeah those they were really good team
they beat us you know in about six
inches of snow that wasn't great I
learned a lot from that game
knows the ball will drop some on Drive
throws not I guess that's doorman up on
arm strength I think that Twitter's yeah
yeah it works some it works most the
time I guess
unlikely to run away from closing
rushers that's that's a little
surprising you know that one that one's
a little surprising uh that's kind of
one of my things you know what's your
what was your 40 I was like bad is like
four nine six okay but you don't have to
run away from him for forty yards only a
couple yards yeah
very little stride and driving his
release I didn't realize we have like
biomechanics majors who work at working
on my throat that's good
scouts are concerned by perceived lack
of arm strength leach had one of the
best quotes about Scouts
[Applause]
you know what I think I think Drew Brees
is coming into the police escort
[Music]
I've lived in New York City I've never
heard more fire trucks in the last three
days than I have here yeah Lee see okay
where were we before uh so rudely
interrupts scouts are concerned by
perceived lack of arm strength I think
it was the great Mike Leach that said
scouts are bad coaches that tell good
coaches who draft I was given a five
point one six prospect grade which
translates to better than average chance
to make an in fo roster I mean that's as
long as I'm better than average you know
that's that could be you know really how
it could be just fifty one I don't know
so we'll take it is also fine now okay
you know so it's okay you know who you
are
ya know for sure like I'm not gonna tell
you no I'm actually six four so it's you
know they got it for the most part you
know but they don't talk about like you
know intelligence or like accuracy
matters you know you got a high
Wonderlic score yeah that was pretty
easy test family should you're joining
us on behalf of Snickers and you
mentioned the chain that you have if you
hold it up again and if you give us all
of the information there yeah so I got
to win Snickers hungriest player this
year is great honor this chain valued at
$75,000 gonna get auctioned off for
Movember I was a great cause for men's
health men's health awareness cancer
awareness mental health awareness you
know stuff that really you know we don't
like to talk about but we probably shed
your the Flavor Flav of quarterbacks
here with your chain there yes
you're looking good hey Congrats on your
new season there there's a lot of fun to
watch a guy said four more Dan Patrick
show tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]